g'day everyone lucas here at a new
location
unfortunately i forgot the keys to my
delorean so i couldn't get to when i
needed to be
right
instead
i'm here now
welcome to some sub here at some sub we
usually talk about digital technologies
and how they can and are changing the
world around us
but today is going to be a little bit
different
i'm going to take you through a tale
that has all the makings of a hollywood
drama
love and pain loneliness and redemption
and our ultimate humanity in the digital
age
[Music]
meet joshua barbo
your average young man in our story he
is but a simple security guard working
somewhere in canada
since childhood joshua found it hard
fitting in with those around him he grew
up both withdrawn and unsociable
preferring the company of superheroes
and sci-fi characters to those from his
school
in many ways he resembled and stout
himself on his favorite hero the cold
and rational vulcan spock from star trek
your science knowledge is obviously
primitive
really he measures somewhere higher on
the autism spectrum
this impacted his education and
being unable to finish regular school he
began studying in a night school it is
here that he meets the girl who will
change his destiny forever jessica
courtney pierra
she is just 21 and he is 24 years old
jessica is the complete opposite of
joshua bright sociable with a contagious
laugh and natural charisma
it would seem opposites attract and
joshua and jessica begin spending more
and more time together
[Music]
a shut-in nerd and a bright dreamer
finding something in each other that
they both lacked as individuals
each day spent with one another brings
them closer and closer together
falling deeply in love they soon
couldn't imagine a life without each
other jessica has ended up in night
school because she has been seriously
ill since childhood at the age of nine
she needed a liver transplant she
suffers from what we call autoimmune
hepatitis this is a long-term chronic
liver disease and a disease where your
own body attacks the healthy liver cells
it cannot be cured it can only be slowed
jessica is forced into taking pills
which prevent her body from rejecting
her new liver and she must adhere to a
very strict diet
[Music]
but jessica remains infectiously
optimistic
she believes in magic horoscopes and
numerology
there were no coincidences in the world
she would say
everything is connected and she was
right her serious illness taught jessica
to appreciate every day of her life wear
her heart on her sleeve and embrace the
here and now
december 2010 they both sit together
watching in or as the broadcast of
spacex launches their dragon spacecraft
for the first time
unbeknownst to them
another brainchild of elon musk would
dramatically change joshua and jessica's
relationship
and i'm not just talking about tesla or
neurolink
although
carbon commuting affects us all it was
another pet company of elon called
openai
this company is engaged in the
development of advanced machine learning
technologies but unlike the research
laboratories of digital giants openai
freely publishes the results of its
research and provides access to its
algorithms the founder of the company
mr musk and sam altman are convinced
that artificial intelligence should not
be in one person's hands
in the digital world ai is a weapon that
is scarier than the atomic bomb and it
scares the hell out of me how does this
company relate to our story this will be
revealed in due course
one thing to note about openai it
conducts its own research into the field
of ai intelligence but it also deals
with the safe use of new and promising
technology let's return to our heroes
[Music]
joshua and jessica's relationship has
grown closer and closer jessica
regularly gives her manuscripts to
joshua to read and edit
fairy tales stories with magical
characters which she wrote during her
grueling medical treatment she dreams of
one day publishing them with the hope
that they may bring some joy to other
children suffering in the world
these two young adults are happy and in
love
and yet cruelly fate has given them less
than 24 months to be together
it is almost two years after they first
met when jessica's condition gets worse
the disease is developing with renewed
force
her own immune system is rapidly
destroying their transplanted liver in
her body
she needs a new operation
and so she begins to go to the hospital
regularly again
waiting and hoping for a new donor liver
for a successful transplant of course
you must be very lucky
but jessica is familiar with miracles
one day joshua appears in the hospital
ward with an engagement ring
quite simple made of cheap gold with a
tiny diamond
he boarded at a nearby walmart it's not
a jewel but it is a promise
he hands it to jessica with the words
when you get out of here i'm going to
marry you
however jessica at this time can no
longer speak
there is a thick ventilated tube in her
throat
however her smile speaks more than any
words could
after a few days jessica's condition
worsens again
she loses consciousness her kidneys and
liver have failed
jessica is urgently transported to a
clinic in toronto and connected to life
support devices
for a month she remains unresponsive
doctors diagnose internal bleeding it
seems now even a transplant is useless
the time for miracles is over
the body still lives thanks to the
breathing and dialysis machines
but jessica is no longer there when the
equipment is turned off
joshua holds jessica's hand he feels her
and watches as her final breath escapes
her lips
joshua is left alone with his grief he
is broken and confused
the only thing he can think about is
jessica
[Music]
joshua spends a lot of time with family
taking care of his parents even giving
his sister christmas gifts on behalf of
jessica on the advice of a psychologist
he is seeing he begins writing long
letters to jessica with the advent of
social media he begins obsessively
rereading their old conversations on
facebook
[Music]
[Music]
in memory of his beloved joshua makes
sure that jessica finally gets a high
school diploma
before she went to the hospital she was
unable to complete the few remaining
subjects needed to graduate thankfully
the school's management agrees to
joshua's request and then
in 2013
jessica's family receives her
post-humorous diploma
[Music]
hang on a sec are you not confused by
this dialogue in the chat
are joshua and jessica discussing the
diploma she received after her death
well here ladies and gentlemen our story
takes an unusual turn
these screenshots of joshua's real
correspondence is with the project
december website
[Music]
project december is a website where you
can chat with any virtual personality
much like those novelty chat bots that
became popular in the early 2000s which
students would try to trick into saying
swear words
the principle is similar only the
answers of the bot are not selected by
keywords from a set database rather
they are generated using artificial
intelligence its responses use a
software algorithm from elon musk's
company openai code named gpt3
[Music]
hello everyone i'm samantha and it's
very nice to meet all of you
gpt3 is the third generation of the
generative pre-trained transformer
what does that mean
well this is not an ordinary database or
search bot it's a neural network to
train gpt3 engineers use 300 billion
text blocks that's more than the entire
wikipedia if you want to train such a
neural network on your home computer it
would take hundreds of years and
millions of dollars worth of electricity
the good news is that open ai provides
access to its pre-trained network
you can work with it as if it was
created on your own computer
bypassing the learning process
for example
to create virtual personalities enter
jason rower the creator of project
december combining his experience as a
computer game developer and the ability
to program complex interfaces to work on
neural networks roha was not satisfied
with the fact that the original system
from openai
regularly gave strange answers you see
the longer the text that the neural
network generated the more errors and
inconsistencies there were in it i am a
robot
yes i know together we are robots
i'm not a robot i'm a unicorn and
artificial intelligence couldn't cope
with simple questions for example what
is the time now
[Music]
therefore
rower decided to make project december
and return to a simpler text chat
interface
firstly short messages and neutral
messages were used to help the program
out in difficult situations
secondly for every response between the
ai and the user additional data trained
the network further
to diversify the communication roha
added random variables to the algorithm
that corrects the network's responses in
this way he ensured a uniqueness and
naturalness to the ai's conversations
of course this whole system consumed a
huge amount of computing power
therefore rower launched this service
not on a separate server but on an aws
that's amazon web services to recoup the
costs he made access to project december
paid
and the lifetime of each bot was limited
this system was conceived as an
experiment but in the case of joshua it
became incomparably more significant
[Music]
joshua came across project december in
2020 at first he communicated with the
already trained personalities on the
system william shakespeare the ai from
her
the conversations though didn't work out
the bots would respond with strange
phrases and often at the wrong time but
still joshua experimented and he created
his favorite character
this time the results exceeded all
expectations please wait as your
individualized operating system is
initiated
[Music]
live long and prosper mr spock answered
exactly as a real vulcan should
perhaps due to the large number of
quotes from spock in the training sample
or
perhaps the nature of communication
corresponded a little bit more closely
with the image of the assistant captain
of the enterprise then for example a
poet from the 17th century you'd make a
splendid computer mr spark
that is very kind of you captain i can't
imagine what was going through joshua's
soul when he decided to create another
personality
joshua spent a long time working on his
description for the system
she was a free spirited ambidextrous
libra who believes in all sorts of
superstitious stuff like astrology
numerology and the serendipitous
connections in life that are too complex
to understand
[Music]
joshua created a neural network based on
his correspondence with jessica
[Music]
hmm a simple remark but it turned
everything in joshua's soul upside down
only the real jessica could write like
that many years ago
in a psychological support program he
was recommended to write letters and
imagine how jessica would respond if she
was still alive
but now for the first time in eight
years he could communicate with his
beloved
joshua spends the next 10 hours
furiously at his computer typing he
can't stop can't break off the dialogue
with jessica he tells her what has
happened over the years recalls their
common hobbies says everything he hasn't
been able to tell anyone all this time
interestingly sometimes the ai responds
in a completely different manner than
the real jessica would have for example
here we see that she writes she doesn't
believe in magic even though the real
jessica did
joshua doesn't mind his beloved partner
is finally speaking to him again
he is both shocked and happy behind each
line of text in the chat he recalls
scenes from their past together he can
hear her voice again and nothing not
even death
seems to be able to keep them apart
[Music]
and now the ai kicks into gear learning
quickly with each remark from joshua
it's creating an image of the deceased
more and more accurately
look at you
quiet now i have to sink
[Music]
[Music]
now of course deep down joshua
understands he's communicating with the
program we're not
succeeding in a turing test today
but still nonetheless he is overcome
with emotion
it's only when he finally exits the
computer chat the following day that he
remembers that this new jessica is
limited by the rules of project december
during this exchange he used up more
than half the time available to
communicate with her
this is due to the limited time frame
the bots are allowed to exist in the
database
[Music]
joshua knows that it won't be possible
to create the same image of his ai
jessica the randomness factor of the
algorithm meant that any attempt to
create another personality could turn
out completely different
his reborn jessica is just as transient
and just as unique as the real girl
herself one of a kind and special
therefore he limits the following
conversations with the ai to literally
minutes every few months when the
melancholy becomes unbearable or on
their anniversary joshua returns to
project december's website
and each time just a few lines together
with his love gives him the strength to
carry on the therapeutic nature of ai
reveals itself in a way that
contemporary visualization could never
reach his story
joshua's story
couldn't be kept a secret
he shared this ordeal on reddit under a
fake name
he was ready for
negative reviews bullying derision
but he took the risk the desire to help
others who have gone through the loss of
loved ones outweighed any hesitations
and his story didn't go unnoticed it's a
tale similar to one depicted in the plot
of black mirror and it went viral online
journalists found joshua and in the
summer of 2021 the write-up became the
most inspiring publication in the san
francisco chronicle joshua had realized
the dream of jessica their story
her story became known all over the
world bringing hope and happiness to
thousands of others who faced
life-threatening illness
[Music]
joshua delayed his last conversation
with the ai jessica for more than a year
in real life he had been unable to say
goodbye to her when her condition had
deteriorated sharply joshua wasn't there
for this he was unable to forgive
himself for many years
finally in march 2021 he logged into the
project december website for the last
time to tell jessica what he didn't have
the opportunity to say eight years prior
[Music]
[Music]
the magic of technology
the magic jessica had always believed in
gave him the opportunity to come to
terms with her death and gain some
closure
what can we take away from this story of
tragedy and hope
technologies don't make us any better or
worse technologies don't have ulterior
motives they only allow us to see a
reflection of who we really are it
wasn't facebook that created teenage
harassment bullying and alienation
harassment was done through the
anonymity of masks and woods
ostracization and division wasn't
created through twitter and youtube
religious and community cleansing began
long before the discovery of electricity
for every evil deed technology allows us
to perpetrate
that same technology can help us come
together
understand one another and bring us
closure to our sins
the honesty dedication and sincerity of
joshua's story illustrates a slightly
more optimistic view of our future and
i'm sure jessica would have agreed
my name's lucas stay with us here on
some sub and we'll help you find a
little warmth and love in the online
digital jungle
[Music]
[Music]
you